by 2020
the minimum wage in Los Angeles is going
to be raised to $15 an hour that's a
minimum wage will be raised which by the
by the way is great news for the members
of my band you can get separate
apartments now you should see their bunk
bed
you guys wake up like The Three Stooges
right exactly yeah you mugs and you all
fall out of bed together
fantastic what else is going on First
Lady Michelle Obama has posted an
exercise video of her beating up a
punching bag don't worry Vice President
Biden is gonna be okay
President Obama by the way has set a
Guinness world record as the fastest
person to get a million Twitter
followers million yes so it's official
Obama now has as many followers as the
Republicans have presidential candidates
so doesn't it feel like a hundred
thousand Republicans a day yet announced
they're running for president and it's
people I don't even know anymore no it's
like I'm Jeff Pitney then then our
ratings are just gonna look like a bus
station guys standing around I'm school
Whitley that's not a name this is crazy
you know the way they seized documents
in the Osama bin Laden raid base yeah
yeah I books and stuff yeah well now
more stuffs coming out this is
fascinating documents seized from Osama
bin Laden's compound suggest he was
concerned about climate change yeah in
other words a guy who wanted to return
the world to the 10th century was still
more progressive than Fox News
[Applause]
he's like everyone must die but the
climate is a problem
my Osama bin Laden he used to do this a
lot 3 Southwest Airlines baggage
handlers are accused of smuggling drugs
in luggage yeah officials became
suspicious when every single one of the
Southwest Airlines bags made it to its
destination zing the joke wasn't enough
I had to give me old Jo right right I'm
over here zinging in Zang and analytic
get this gang in Israel that's right
Israel a 65 year old woman 65 year old
woman has given birth to a baby yeah
there's already some jealousy from the
babies older brother a retired
sheetmetal worker
what about Leo II that's insanity
it's a 40-year age difference according
to a new survey roughly a quarter of
drivers report using Facebook while
driving
yes this explains the hottest new thing
being posted on Facebook last selfies
[Applause]
that's the absolute worst no one would
feel sorry for that guy or girl
gender-neutral hey guess what hey thanks
for watching please subscribe to my
youtube channel so they will stop making
me shoot these videos